[MUSIC PLAYING]
OWEN LIN: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to "Ten Best Practices
for High-Quality Actions."
I'm Owen.
I'm a product manager
for Actions on Google.
ERICA CEI: I'm Erica.
I'm a linguist.
And I help developers learn how
to design great conversations
between people and machines.
SHIKHA SEHGAL: I'm Shikha.
I'm a partner
technology manager.
My team works with
developers and partners
to help them build
high-quality Actions.
OWEN LIN: And we're
really excited to have you
with us today.
Actions on Google
is the platform
for developing conversational
experiences for the Google
Assistant.
By building and
deploying an Action,
you can make your
product or service
available to all the
users of the Assistant.
Today, we're going to
share some tips for how
to build high-quality Actions.
Between the three
of us, we've worked
with hundreds of developers.
So we're really excited to
share our experience of what's
worked best.
Now, before we jump in to how
to build high-quality Actions,
let's spend a moment and
talk about why we should
build high-quality Actions.
Why does quality matter?
Well, one very important
reason for building
high-quality Actions is that
it leads to happy users.
But another really
important reason
is that high-quality
Actions increases
the chances of your Action
being promoted by Google.
The higher the quality
of your Action,
the more likely Google is to
drive traffic to your Action--
for example, through
the Assistant Directory,
through implicit
invocation, even
through Google
Marketing newsletters.
We've observed that, on
average, high-quality Actions
receive about two to 10 times
the traffic as other Actions.
So we know that quality is
very important for traffic.
The next question
you might be asking
is, how does Google
measure quality?
Well, the answer
to that is twofold.
The first component is, how do
users respond to your Action?
Do users like your Action?
And to measure
that, we would look
at a number of usage metrics--
for example, engagement
rate, cancellation rate,
user ratings, et
cetera, et cetera.
The second component
to this is, is this
statistically significant?
OK, great, so the metrics
say that your users
love your Action.
Do we have enough
traffic to your Action
so that we can trust what
the numbers are saying?
And this talk will go through
both of these components.
Number one, we'll talk
about how to build
an Action that users love.
And number two,
we'll talk about how
to drive some initial
traffic to your Action.
Our goal is that by the end
of our 40 minutes together,
you'll be able to build a
high-quality Action that boosts
your chances of being promoted.
Our talk will take us through
the entire development cycle,
from planning to
implementation to launch.
Let's get started with planning.
ERICA CEI: So the first
and most important step
is to pick the right
conversational use
case, because the use
case is the foundation
that everything else on
your Action is built on.
Now, the keyword here
is "conversational."
You want to make sure that
your Action is really leaning
into the power of voice.
So how do we do that?
One thing you can ask
yourself is, would this
save the user time and
effort as a conversation?
Let's take, for example,
adding an event to my calendar.
I could do that with more
than 10 taps on my phone,
or I could just do
it with one utterance
and already have the event
title, date, and time saved.
So that seems like a clear win.
Another thing you can
do is look to real life
as your inspiration.
If something is already
getting done in the real world
through conversation, it's
probably a natural fit
for an Action, as well.
That also means
that your users can
apply their real-world
knowledge to the Action, which
really lowers the learning curve
and makes it easier for them.
One example of that is, we
order coffee from baristas
with our voice all the time.
And so it should be pretty easy
to adapt that to Action form.
Once you have some
use cases in mind,
you can gut check them
by asking yourself,
how do people usually do
this, and kind of compare
the distance between
that and how they're
doing it in your Action.
So again, when it comes
to ordering coffee,
we said people do that with
baristas through their voice
all the time.
So it's not too big of a
jump to do it with an Action.
On the other hand, what
about something like,
you're browsing through
local coffee shops,
looking for the perfect
coffee experience,
you want to read all
those reviews and ratings.
At that point, you might be
more interested in something
browsing a map or seeing
a bar graph of the rating
distributions, scrolling
through pages of reviews.
And so that would
be a bit harder
to translate into Action
form and maybe wouldn't
lend itself as easily.
This tip alone could
be its own talk.
There's so much more
to say about it.
And it actually was in 2017 here
at I/O. So I really recommend
that you go on YouTube and
look up this talk by Daniel
Padgett from 2017--
"Finding the Right Voice
Interactions for Your App."
OK.
So you have your use case.
You've started figuring
out what the flows are
going to look like.
Now you want to think about
the details of how exactly
your Action is going to speak.
And I really recommend that you
incorporate the user's history
with the Action so
that that's reflected
in what it says to them.
When you go to a coffee
shop for the first time--
just to give a concrete,
real life example--
the barista might
welcome you, ask you
if you need any
recommendations, tell you
what the featured drinks are,
ask what you'd like to order.
But after you keep coming
there day after day
and you always order
the same exact drink,
it gets to the
point where you walk
in, the barista
makes eye contact
and recognizes you, and
just says, "The usual?"
And that sort of
efficiency can only
happen because of
the shared history.
We want to go for something
similar in our Actions.
This is a strategy
that we call tapering.
And it's all about optimizing
the prompt for the user.
This can make it
much more efficient.
And it also feels
more personalized
and more intelligent.
And the fact that it's
speaking naturally,
the way that a
person might, also
means that the user feels more
comfortable speaking naturally
back to it, which makes
it, again, easier for them.
To see this applied
to an Action,
let's say that we are building
a coffee-ordering Action,
and the user is choosing
where to pick up that coffee.
Maybe the first time, it's
suggesting a specific store
and asking if they
want to get it there.
But after they keep
picking up from there,
we can just use this
shortened prompt.
And you can see how
much faster that is,
as well as being personalized.
So now that you've thought
about how your Action is going
to talk, you should think
about the other half
of the conversation.
How is the user going to talk?
You want to make sure that
they can speak naturally.
And what do we mean
by "naturally"?
Well, when people
talk to each other,
they express themselves
in a wide variety of ways.
And so we want our
Action to also understand
a wide variety of utterances.
That way, the user
doesn't have to worry
about things like
memorizing commands
to interact with your Action.
They can just talk
spontaneously, and it'll work.
That makes it more
comfortable for them.
Your Action will
also come across
as smarter and friendlier.
Again, to see this in
the context of what
it would look like
in an Action, let's
say that I've made an ice
cream-ordering app for my ice
cream shop.
And towards the end
of the user's order,
the Action asks if they
want sprinkles on that.
I want everyone to take a
moment to think of a few ways
that they would say yes--
yes, we want sprinkles.
How are we going to say that?
Well, here's a few ways.
Here's a few more,
and still more.
And I'm sure there's
tons of other ones
that are not even on this slide.
So how can we solve
for this easily?
Well, let's go over the basics.
First, this is done by building
out the recognition grammars.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with the term,
a recognition grammar is the
set of phrases and utterances
that your Action can
recognize and understand.
And the basic way
to build this out
is, you kind of come up
with a list of responses
that a user might come up with.
And then you want
to go beyond what
your own brain can
come up with and tap
into other people's brains.
Ideally, you'll test
with your users.
But if they're
not available, you
can ask your friends
or co-workers.
Then start coming up with
variations on everything that's
in the list.
And then once you have
maybe beta testers,
you can start checking the logs
to see if anything you missed
slipped through the cracks and
use that to plug those holes.
But how can we
make it super easy?
That's with Dialogflow.
Dialogflow is our
tool that you can
use for building Actions
and doing a lot more.
I really recommend
that you use it,
because it can do
a lot of cool stuff
that we'll go through right now.
It is particularly strong
in building grammars.
I actually call that
Dialogflow's superpower.
So one really great feature is
pre-built follow-up intents--
that is, grammars that are made
for you for some really common
user intents, like the
"yes" that we were talking
about for the sprinkles before.
And then there's also "no,"
"cancel," and a few other ones.
And you can actually
edit these grammars,
so you can customize
them to be a perfect fit
to your specific prompt, which
I really recommend that you do.
But this is a huge
time-saver, a great shortcut.
You can also use
system entities which
let your Action understand some
common categories of words,
like colors, numbers,
or one of my favorites
is the example that
we see on the screen--
date-time.
It can understand anything from
3:15 to two weeks from Friday
and put that into a standardized
form, which is pretty cool.
It's really powerful.
And for everything else,
there's machine learning.
You can fill in a few sample
phrases in the Training Phrases
section.
And Dialogflow will
generalize from there.
So see here for the
ice cream-ordering app,
I have one utterance that
says, "a scoop of this,
a scoop of that," and
then another utterance
at the bottom that's saying
a flavor and then a topping.
And then when this user
utterance comes along,
which is not in the grammar
and it's not even a form
that's in the grammar,
because we have a combo--
we have a scoop of this, a scoop
of that, and also the topping--
my Action is going
to understand this
no problem, because it was able
to generalize from those seeds
that I put in there.
If you want a deep
dive on Dialogflow,
I suggest you come back
to this same exact stage
tomorrow at 2:30 for the
session called "Let's Talk."
It'll be really helpful.
But even if you build the
best grammar in the world,
there's still going to be times
when your users get stuck.
And you want to make
sure that you're
able to get them unstuck.
And the key to that
is using the context.
By "context," I mean the stuff
that was already established
earlier on in the conversation.
So why do we need
to worry about this?
Even when people talk to each
other, we mess up all the time.
Think back to maybe the
last time you stumbled
over your words or
someone said something
and you didn't quite understand.
But we recover so flawlessly
that we don't really
even notice this.
So what does this tell us?
One thing is that
if we mess up when
we're talking to
each other, we're
definitely going to mess up
when we talk to machines, too.
The other thing is, if we are
able to recover and still move
on, maybe we can do something
similar in our Action.
Let's see an example
of how Starbucks
did this in their Action.
And you're also welcome to try
this Action yourself later on.
So it's towards the
end of the order.
Starbucks is asking the user
what size drink they want.
It doesn't understand
what the user says.
And so it re-prompts by
saying, "Sorry, what size?"
And the user is able to
get right back on track.
Research shows that when errors
are handled smoothly like this,
users don't even
remember that they
happened, which is good in
terms of user happiness.
And it also means that users
are staying in your Action
longer, because they're
not error-ing out.
So this is super important.
Let's break down why
this specific prompt
was so effective.
The number one key is that it
mentions the context again.
In this case, that was the size.
By mentioning the
size again, it's
kind of reiterating what
the key piece of info
is that it needs and
kind of focuses on that.
It also sounds like it's
making the conversation
with the user on the spot.
So for example, you could also
try this with a generic prompt,
like, "What was that?"
But then you risk things
like the user maybe
repeating something that
they had said already.
Here, by emphasizing
the size, we're
making sure they stick to
providing that piece of info.
It's also really quick.
So again, you might think,
well, couldn't I just repeat
the same question and that
would also repeat the context?
Yes, but that would
be really unnatural.
People would not do
that in conversation.
And so it makes it harder for
the user to interact naturally.
And also, if they
tried to respond,
that means that they
just heard the question.
So they don't need to sit
through the whole thing again.
You can just shorten it
and make it more efficient.
That "sorry" at the
beginning is also a clue
that maybe things didn't go
quite as well as anticipated.
So that's a good
clue to the user.
And again, this
sounds very natural,
so it's easy to interact with.
This style of error reprompt
is called a rapid reprompt.
And our data shows that this
style is effective with users,
and they like it.
One note is, because
it's contextual,
that does mean you'll need one
of these prompts for everything
that your Action says.
But the win in quality
is well worth that.
And also, it's much
easier to write these
than you might first think.
You can learn more about how to
do that in depth on our design
guidelines here.
And those also go into
depth into other scenarios
that I didn't get into here,
like what if you reprompt
and then the Action
still doesn't understand?
Or what if the user doesn't
say anything at all?
So you can definitely check
out the guidelines, learn that.
It also covers all kinds
of other scenarios related
to the plan and
design of an Action.
So that's it for planning.
Let's dive into implementation.
OWEN LIN: All right.
So now we're getting
into implementation.
And our first tip
for implementation
is around devices.
In particular,
our recommendation
is to build for speakers
first, then build for screens.
One of the great things
about building for the Google
Assistant is that it's available
on over 1 billion devices,
ranging from smartphones to
speakers to smart displays,
watches, even cars.
I really love that you
can build your Action once
and potentially
have it available
on so many different devices.
Now, building for
all these devices
doesn't need to be difficult.
And our tip for making it
a little bit more simple
is to start with speakers first
and then extend your Action
to the screen.
We found that doing it this
way is a lot easier than going
the other way around.
And because all of the
Google Assistant devices
respond to voice,
you get the most bang
for your buck in this way.
So once you've
taken Erica's tips
and you come up with a
great conversational design,
then it's time to start
thinking about extending
your Action to the screens.
And we'll go over
some ways that you
can do that through this step.
So let's take a scenario.
Let's say you decided
that you wanted
to build an air quality Action.
And this Action, if your
user is on a speaker,
then you want your Action to
say what the air quality is.
And if they're on a
device with a screen,
then you want your Action to
expand the Action a little bit
more with visuals.
Here's how we might
actually be able to do this.
So now we're going to
your fulfillment code.
Here we're in the
Intent, where the user
has asked for the air quality.
And what we're going
to do is, first, we're
going to check to
see if the user is
on a device with a screen.
So that's what we're
doing in line 1.
In step 2, if the user has
a device with a screen,
then we can create a basic
card, put an image on it,
and then show it in
the conversation.
If the user doesn't
have a screen,
then we can just speak what
the air quality is-- so very
simple.
And this is what the
experience would actually
look like for the user.
So here, the user asks for the
air quality on their phone.
And they got a basic
card with an image
that helps them to
extend the air quality.
So this is fairly basic.
For your Action, feel free to
extend the card a little bit
more and make it
a little bit more
engaging for folks
on the screen.
Now let's talk about a
more advanced technique.
So let's say, in addition to
telling your users the air
quality in their
location, you also
want to show them a map of the
air quality around their area.
So this is probably
going to be pretty
hard to do for a speaker.
But fortunately,
Actions on Google
has a really nifty
feature that actually
lets you transfer your user from
one device to another device.
And so in this
particular example,
if your user is
on a speaker, you
can actually request for
them to go from the speaker
to a device with a screen.
And this is how you
would actually do it.
So we're back in your
fulfillment code.
We're back in the Intent,
where the user has
asked for an air quality map.
And what we're going
to do is, in step 1,
we're going to create a variable
called Screen Available.
And here we're going to store
the results of the function
that checks to see
if the user has
a screen available for
any one of their devices.
In step 2, if the
user is already
on a device with a screen,
then we'll show the map.
But if the user isn't on
a device with a screen,
then we'll create a
new surface object.
And what this new
surface object does
is it requests that
the user transfers
from their current
device to another device.
In this particular
example, we're
asking the user to transfer
to a device with a screen.
And then we're going to
show this new surface
object in the conversation.
Lastly, we'll check to make
sure that the user has actually
accepted the transfer or not.
And this is what the experience
would look like for the users.
All right.
So say they're on
the screen, and they
ask for an air quality map.
We request that they transfer
to a device with a screen.
They say yes.
On their phone, they'll
get a notification
from your air quality
Action asking them
to continue the conversation.
If they click into
this notification,
they'll bring up the Action
with the air quality map loaded.
So they can pick up right
where they left off.
I think this is a
really nifty feature
to really help you be with
your users wherever they are.
Now, we've only scratched
the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to developing
for multiple surfaces.
If you guys are interested
in learning more,
we have another talk
right after this one
around this exact topic.
So feel free to stick
around if you're
interested in learning more.
OK.
Great.
So we've talked about how
to simplify development
for different devices.
Our next tip is around
simplifying your code.
And the recommendation here
is to make your life easier
with Helpers.
Helpers are pre-built components
that Google has already created
for very common use cases.
And let's take an example to
see how Helpers might work.
Let's say you want to
build a taxi Action.
As part of this Action, you want
to ask the user for an address
to send a taxi to.
Well, what's the
best way to do this?
You can actually use a Helper
to make your life a lot easier.
And the way we're going to
do that is, here in step 1,
we're going to create
a place object.
And then within
the conversation,
we're going to invoke
the place object.
Now, after the user has
given their address,
you can check the place object
for the user's response.
Now, you'll notice a
couple things here.
So first of all, you didn't
have to write any code
to parse the user's
address from their voice.
Google's done that
already for you.
Number two, you didn't have
to worry about error handling.
Google has also
done that for you.
And number three,
your user's response
is in a very easily
accessible format
through the place object.
So overall, instead of
writing many lines of code,
you just had to write
a few lines of code,
using the address Helper.
It makes your code a lot
simpler and a lot easier.
This is what the experience
looks like for the user.
So the Action will ask
the user for the address.
The user will give the address.
And very quickly, you'll be able
to use the address directly.
In addition to
simplifying your code,
these Helpers also simplify
the user experience,
because it standardizes it
across many different Actions.
So we highly recommend
that you use them.
In addition to the
place Helper, we
have a number of other Helpers
that you might find useful.
For example, we
have Helpers that
allow you to get the user's
name, their location, the date
and time, et cetera, et cetera.
One Helper that
we think deserves
its own tip, in particular,
is around account linking.
Use account linking
to personalize
the user's experience.
Account linking allows
you to connect your Action
to your own
authentication system.
So let's take a scenario.
Let's say that you're the
owner of a pizza shop,
and you have your
own web app, and you
have your own app that
allows users to order pizzas
from you directly.
Let's say you also have an
Assistant Action that lets you
check the status of your order.
Now, in order for users
to actually do this,
they'll have to sign
in to your system.
And the way they do this
is through account linking.
And to do this is
actually super simple.
So in your Actions Console,
the first thing you need to do
is to enable account linking.
Then back in your
fulfillment code,
you can create a
sign-in object and then
invoke it in the conversation.
Lastly, you need to check to
see if the user has successfully
signed in or not.
But the entire flow takes just a
few lines of code to build out.
And this is what it will
look like for your users.
Here, your users ask you for
the status of their pizza.
Google will allow them
to check to see if they
have an account with you.
If they do, then they can grant
permission to your pizza data
through your Action.
And if they grant
permission, then they'll
be able to get the
status of their pizza
directly from your Action.
So super simple, from a user
perspective-- two clicks,
they're signed in
to your system.
We've seen that when
users successfully sign in
to their Actions,
their engagement rate
with your Action
grows significantly.
Here's some recommendations
for making sure
that your sign-in
rate stays high.
First, ask in the right context.
So in the previous example,
we asked for sign-in
after the user has asked to
check their pizza status.
Here, the user knows why they
need to sign in to the Action.
They know what value they're
going to get by signing in.
We've worked with
a few other Actions
in the past that ask for sign-in
as soon as the user opens
the Action.
And what we observed is that
users tend not to sign in,
and they also tend not to
return to the Action afterwards.
So the lesson here is,
ask in the right context
so the user knows what the
value of signing in is.
The second recommendation
here is to use Google Sign-In.
So we offer several options
for account linking,
including OAuth.
But Google Sign-In is
the preferred method.
And the reason for
that is threefold.
So number one, a lot
of Assistant users
have already signed in
to their Google accounts.
So using Google
Sign-In is really easy.
We saw in the previous example,
it only took the users two taps
to successfully sign in.
The second reason is, if you
use Google Sign-In and the user
doesn't have an account
with your system already,
they can create a
new account, which
is good for the growth
of your product.
And then number
three, Google Sign-In
is already built for
both voice and visual,
so you get the most bang
for your buck by using it.
And that's it for
account linking.
Next, we'll go into
launch and growth.
SHIKHA SEHGAL: Now that you
have implemented your Action,
are you ready to launch it?
Not quite yet.
This brings us to our
next best practice.
A common theme that
we have seen with most
of our high-quality Actions
is they do extensive testing
with selected early adopters.
It's like doing a soft
opening for a restaurant.
Have you been to one?
A new restaurant owner, before
they open their restaurant
to the public, they
do a series of nights.
They call it soft opening.
They invite a few
family and friends
who enjoy a good dining
experience and some critics,
who can give them true,
honest, real feedback
on the food, the restaurant,
the service, et cetera.
We want you to do something
very similar with your Actions.
And to help you, we have created
two release channels for you.
First is an alpha release.
Alpha is an awesome way
to do quick iterations
for your Action.
When you are in the
early stages, when you've
done your manual testing,
open up your Action
to your immediate team members.
You can select up to 20
testers at this point.
Your Action does not
undergo a Google review.
So whatever changes
you make will go live
in just a couple of hours.
So this will really allow
you to do early iterations.
We recommend that you
select your testers
from your employees within your
team and some extended team.
At Google, we call
this team folding.
And we do this pretty
much for all our products.
Once you do alpha and
you feel comfortable,
expand your testers to what
we call a beta release.
You can select up to
200 testers for this.
Before your Action
goes live to beta,
it goes through a
full Google review.
We check for policy compliance.
And you decide when you want
it to go live in production.
We recommend that you
select your beta users
from mostly folks outside of
your org and include a variety.
When you do alpha and beta
release, make it count.
My team incubates new features
for Actions in Google.
We do alpha and beta extensively
with our early access partners
and developers.
And here's how we
make the most of it.
We want you to do same
with your Actions.
First, give basic
instructions to your testers.
Give them some basic
expressions that they should use
and tell them the
goal of your Action.
But don't tell them too much.
You want your testers
to struggle a bit.
This helps you capture
their edge cases.
Next, be there in person.
Sit and watch them, if possible.
We understand it might
be impossible to do
this with all your testers.
But even if you can
with a selected few,
it would really
make the difference.
It will help you
capture their body
language, their
expressions, the way
they interact with your Action.
And you don't want to
miss this deep feedback.
Finally, use a diverse
set of testers--
ideally, a sample that
represents your actual user
base--
people from
different age groups,
different genders,
backgrounds, some tech savvy,
some non-tech savvy.
This helps you capture
a broad perspective
and helps you cover a
good range of use cases.
And when ready, go live.
But once you go live,
how do your users
know that your Action exists?
Let's say you created a game--
a very cool game.
But your users don't know.
Let me show you two simple steps
in which some of our developers
have been able to boost the
discovery of their Actions
and increase their daily active
users by up to five-fold.
Do you know how most
of the Assistant users
use when they want
to play a game?
They simply say, "play a game."
And when they do
that, Assistant shows
them a list of five top games.
You can further
filter down using
a category of your choice.
It will give you
a filtered list.
I like math.
Say, "Go to Math Showdown."
And then you can start
playing that game.
You did not know what game
you wanted to play with.
Assistant helped you
narrow down the choice.
But how do we make your
game appear in this list?
"Play game" was one way
to express what we call,
in an Assistant
world, your intent.
There could be hundreds more.
You can see a sample
on the screen.
Now you can go ahead
and add all of these
to your Action as
custom variables.
But it might be
impossible to capture
all possible variations.
We have done this work
for you by something
called built-in intent.
A built-in intent maps
hundreds or thousands of these
variations into one common
variable that you can simply
add to your Action--
in this particular
case, "play game."
and when added,
your Action becomes
eligible to appear in that list.
It's very simple to add this
built-in intent to your Action.
You simply go to
Dialogflow, select
an intent of your choice.
You can further
specify the category
that your game fits in, like
music, education, et cetera.
And that enhances your
chances of appearing
in that filtered list.
Besides "play game," we have
14 other built-in intents
that are available today.
They are in developer preview,
so you can apply to use them.
We created these based on
the most popular use cases
that we see on Assistant and
what our developers, like you,
love to build.
If you see a built-in
intent that's not here,
you can always apply for
it through our website.
We plan to continue
to add to this list.
Remember, it's important to
select the right built-in
intent, but also very important
to ensure that your Action is
high quality.
Owen earlier mentioned
certain metrics
that we use to measure the
quality of your Action--
how a user responds to it, the
success rate, the error rate,
et cetera.
A combination of right built-in
intent and high quality
really boosts the
chances of your Action
to appear in this list.
But what if you're
not a game or you
don't fit into any of the
other 14 built-in intents
that I showed?
We have other option for you.
It's called action links.
These are simple hyperlinks
that take a user from the link
directly to your Action.
When used right, these can be
a great discovery mechanism
for your Action.
And it's very simple
to generate them.
Simply go to your Actions
Console, give a title,
and get the URL.
We publish it for you.
Just copy it and use
it on your website,
on your blog, social media,
or wherever a link works.
Let me show you a
very cool way in which
one of our Italian
developers, Giallo Zafferano,
used action links.
Now, they have some
amazing Italian recipes.
And when you go
to their website--
and say you're visiting this
pasta recipe, which I really
like, you see this
cool, floating Assistant
badge on their site.
And when you click
this Assistant badge,
it takes you to the exact Action
and pasta recipe in Assistant.
And it takes you
through the actual steps
to make that pasta.
You can start cooking
hands-free right away.
How cool is that?
Giallo Zafferano, when they
launched this experience,
they saw a significant spike
in their daily active users.
And at the same time,
they were able to give
this innovative and
cool cooking experience
for their food-loving users.
This is one way you can get
creative in your own way
when you use action links.
Now that you got that spike
in daily active users,
how do you sustain it?
How do you keep your users
engaged and reengaged?
We want you to become a part
of your users' daily routine.
Users like you and I
have some daily habits.
For example, in my morning,
I like to check the weather,
listen to the news, see my
calendar, and plan my day.
In the evening, I like to wind
down, listen to some music.
Assistant today has some
pre-built-in Routines for you.
And users can add
multiple Actions
to each of these Routines.
And they can invoke them
using a single command.
You can make your Action
eligible for these Routines.
Let me show you how.
I like to use Headspace
for my meditation.
Say I'm talking to Headspace.
I select today's
meditation of my choice.
And when I'm listening to
this meditation, I like it.
I see this option to
add it to a Routine.
When I select it, it
would ask me to confirm.
I say yes.
Then it gives me
the option to add it
to one of my existing Routines.
I select Bedtime.
And that's it.
I was able to add Headspace
and that meditation
to my Bedtime Routine.
And let's see what happens
when I invoke Bedtime.
Assistant remembers
that I added Headspace
and that exact meditation,
and it will play it for me.
How simple is this experience
from the previous one?
I didn't need to remember
Headspace or need
to select a meditation.
Assistant did it for me.
You can do this with
your own Actions.
And if, say, you think
your Action is not
good fit for Routines, we
have other options for you.
Daily Updates--
these are updates
which Google pulls from your
Action at a time specified
by the user.
So for example, I like to get
a yoga routine in my morning
or want to check
my stock portfolio.
Other option is
Notifications when
your Action decides
when it wants
to send an update to the user.
For example, say,
hey, your pizza
will arrive in 10 minutes, or
your movie tickets are ready.
Enjoy your show tomorrow.
It's very easy to include any
of these user engagement tools
to your Action.
Simply go to your
Actions Console
and enable the ones
that you see fit.
So those were our
ten best practices
to plan, implement, launch,
and grow your Action.
My team has been working
with Actions in Google
since we launched it.
Over the years, we have
seen the challenges
that our developers and
partners have faced.
We know what works
and what doesn't.
And what we shared
with you today
are our learnings from closely
working with those developers.
We hope you're able to use them.
And mind that you can use all
of these best practices today.
They work for you.
Let's do a quick recap.
When you plan, make sure
you pick the right use case.
Let your users speak
naturally and help them
when they get into an error
or when they get stuck.
When you implement, build for
speakers first, then screen.
Leverage Helpers when
possible, and give your users
a personalized experience using
Action, using account linking.
Finally, before you
launch your Action,
early test with early
adopters using alpha and beta,
boost discovery using action
links and built-in intent,
and meet your users where
they are by becoming
a part of their daily routines.
Remember, high-quality Action
makes your users happy.
And in turn, it makes
your Action eligible
to be promoted by Google,
which, in turn, drives
more users to your Action.
There are several more
resources available at I/O
to help you learn more.
I'm highlighting
a couple of talks.
We are also available to talk
to you in person at the Sandbox,
Office Hours, and Codelab.
We would love to talk to
you, answer your questions,
and help you get
started, so do visit us.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]